the Joe Rogan experience your my
commitment
well I'm max Holloway spinning a little
[ __ ] cap at the bottom thank you and
then they got the guitar played did it
yeah what's his name mayor mayor did so
did max highway invented it I don't know
how I just saw it on and see the first
person I saw yeah like that's amazing
that's that's amazing
max Holloway is the but he's such a
[ __ ] cool guy I love that guy
when plays the show he's a champion
he'll come back like who the [ __ ] comes
is better than him yeah the way he draws
to Dustin Poirier excuses all love all
happiness he's amazing Jason Statham
what's he doing what's going to know let
me see he's a real karate guy Jason
Statham has real striking skills like
what look like he could tell even the
way he's stand-in here like the way he's
moving no no he's gonna spend it but you
see even the way he's doing it like this
guy's got real skill look at that
Kapow he um he achieved a very high
level of skill in karate I don't know
exactly what it was but from people that
I know that I've done martial arts with
him and train with him I said that guy's
a bad [ __ ] like a legit badass
really knows martial arts I believe it
right you see him you like I believe it
see him in like snatch one of those
movies like yeah you [ __ ] people up
[Applause]